welcome to this video click the jug you
later this doesn't sound too nice oops
from from Israel and let's play this
side line against the Sicilian with no
niji 30 this is uncommon this g6 because
this looks so wow really and yeah
sometimes it really amazes what what
what kind of stuff check gets played ok
boy was have 96cm can just Queenie for
probably
and yeah just castles on is there
something better I wonder about Bishop
f4 of course
yeah I probably can can just can just
take take on b2 we go Knight c3 that's a
six gods are not so great oh come on I
really want to punish him for that but
maybe this is the wrong moment not sure
didn't really calculate it's a bit of a
gamble but you know I didn't go for that
really really should I think okay one or
the check yeah why not to check actually
I will he will take and night c7 checked
27 Queen takes Queen takes e6 Fe Bishop
d7 95 yeah dlp to us hanging ok I need
to retreat
check I don't get it alas resign I don't
get anything in this game yeah just 97
next door whatever winning huge material
yeah this really really weird game but
probably from both sides well yamaha
after night b5 I think black is almost
almost almost lost how do you how do you
prevent this 96 check yeah and this
check here maybe there's something
better here somewhere your computer once
sir castles yeah Bishop f4 is really
really gamble I thought he'd hoped you
wouldn't take after that turn yeah it's
not clear Kim yeah he really should play
that it's it's it's playable let's play
a little black also note this move it
sound quite interesting something like
that is immediately winning for black
this was really a crap game by both
sides cat can I need to Castle him
Bishop f4 was really not very rage
rational i was i was a bit afraid about
this move i can just go back yeah well
black I said somehow quite quite nicely
developed it's really hard to believe
that this should be a playable move or
should I do something else is there
better move than taking like hmm yeah
but this must be right really check
curious really curious okay this was bad
but Castle it's night f6 yeah well this
is probably probably an issue yeah well
it's still tricky I mean it looks really
insane for black to play like that but
maybe it's still it's still possible
without being being lost out right
really strange yeah well whatever black
shouldn't really play six mg 6 in this
position this is quite similar to to the
Kings Indian attack with d3 to show the
difference there's this line and tier
white can play this and this is really
questionable for black and here I have a
complete an additional tempo with the
default in one move so this really
shouldn't be playable but as we saw it
it's still quite tricky thanks for
watching